new signs of cruelty and terror on
russia's war on ukraine
we've got video that appears to show an
ambulance being hit by shelling in the
parking lot of a hospital and then the
bbc captured this footage from a suburb
of kiev where entire apartment blocks
were destroyed and hundreds are feared
dead here ukraine says this is just more
evidence that russia is intentionally
killing civilians this morning pope
francis held up a ukrainian flag during
this weekly audience he said it came
from bucha where the ukrainians say
there's evidence of mass killings there
holly williams is in ukraine holly good
morning to you these this video is still
so upsetting to see
yeah it really is gail good morning
ukrainian prosecutors say that they're
investigating nearly 4 500 alleged war
crimes by russian troops and ukraine's
prosecutor general says they want to
quote punish the monsters who are
responsible we should warn you that our
report contains some disturbing material
the cruelty of russian troops in butcher
the inhumanity of what they inflicted on
civilians is painful to look at
but ukrainian investigators can't turn
away instead they're documenting it
including these charred corpses because
russia's been accused of war crimes
that house
you can see maybe three and
their house it's maybe one body
ukraine's interior minister dennis
monisterski has this message for
vladimir putin go to hell
irina abrov mova says her husband oleg
was the love of her life
and describes how he was executed by the
russians
they took him from our home in his
slippers she says
asked him to take his shirt off made him
kneel on the ground and killed him this
shocking video apparently shows a
civilian killed on his bike and this
drone footage from late february appears
to capture a cyclist turning a corner
onto what looks like the same street and
immediately being fired upon by a
russian vehicle
in the city of la viv there was a
candlelit vigil last night for ukraine's
civilian victims in the colours of the
national flag we want to pray for
ukraine we hope that our nation
will win
this
war
but it's not just butcher other towns
and villagers have also reported horrors
while under russian occupation
ukrainians the slaughter of their own
people is heart-rending and fueling the
fight to protect their homeland and
their freedom whatever the cost
we were given rare access to a ukrainian
military hospital where they treat
soldiers wounded on the front line we
can't show their faces for security
reasons
mykola is a mechanic and reservist who
told us he was hit by shrapnel in a fire
fight with the russians
we can't stop them on our own he told us
we have to rely on support from the west
something needs to be done because this
will go on and on
many ukrainians have expressed to us
their gratitude for american help in
this conflict but some are also
frustrated because they want more
weapons especially aircraft and modern
air defense systems
tony
it's understandable holly williams force
in ukraine holly thank you very much